اخرجت فرق الانقاذ
التابعه لايها مؤسسه الاغاثه التركيه
خمسه اشخاص من تحت الانقاذ بعد قضائهم 130
ساعه تحت الانقاذ هي عباره عن عائله من
الام وثلاثه اطفال نحن نريد ان نعطيكم
صوره اوضح للدمار والخراب في مدينه نورداغ
من خلال كاميرا الجزيره الطائره التي
نحاول ان نشاهد فيها حجم الدمار الهائل
الذي حل بهذه المدينه
وكيف تعمل فرق الانقاذ وكيف تعمل فرق
المساعدات والخيم التي نصبت في مدينه
نورداغ هذه المدينه التي
تعداد سكانها ما يقرب من خمسين الف مواطن
اصبح 80% منهم بلا سكن تركوا منازلهم
واصبحوا خارج هذه
المنازل هذا الذي تشاهدونه في الصوره هو
مجمع سكني عباره عن خمسه بنايات كل بنايه
مكونه من س طوابق كل طابق مكون من ثلاثه
شقق سكنيه انهار بالكامل على ساكنه
واخرج عدد قليل احياء والباقي خرج اخرجوا
امواتا من داخل هذه المدينه ايضا الدمار
اينما تنظر في مدينه نورداغ تجد ان احياء
قد سقطت بالكامل نحن نشاهد بنايات
قصيره وبنايه طويله هذه الدمار هذه
المناطق الفارغه كانت عباره عن عمارات
سكنيه انهارت وتم ازاله وانقاضها من قبل
فرق الانقاذ هذه العمارات السكنيه التي
نشاهدها هي عباره عن بنايات غير صالحه
للسكن اي خرجت عن الخدمه وهي فارغه تماما
من كل ساكنها لا يوجد كلهم توجهوا اما الى
الخيام اما الى الطرقات واما الى مناطق
اخرى خارج مدينه بلده نور هو كل البلدات
المجاوره لبلده نوردا هي متضرره مثل هذا
الضرر الذي نشاهده